la désoccupation de la rive droite de la
région de Kerson et de la ville de
Carson et dans sa face finale il y a
beaucoup de travail à faire pour
nettoyer la zone et déminer la ville
nous comprenons que les occupants ont
détruit la centrale thermique et la
station de distribution d'électricité de
la région près de la tour de télévision
ils ont détruit un local électrique nous
devons tout réparer
voilà pour les combats qui sont donc
désormais terminés mais les autorités
ukrainiennes n'appellent tout de même la
population à la plus grande des
vigilants s’écouter Gulliver crack il
est notre correspondant dans le pays
les autorités à KF mettent en garde
aussi contre la possibilité que tous les
soldats russes ne soient pas réellement
partis de la ville de Herson il y a eu
beaucoup d'informations dernièrement sur
la possibilité qui se soit déguisé en
civile qu'ils se cacherait dans les
maisons à Herson on a tendance l'armée
ukrainienne qui arriverait et c'est bien
ce qui semble être en train de se passer
aujourd'hui l'arrivée de l'armée
ukrainienne une première photo a fait
surface en ligne de soldats Ukrainiens
dont la banlieue nord-ouest de la ville
de Herson et tout de suite les habitants
de la ville dans le centre-ville on
réagi en sortant avec des drapeaux
Ukrainiens sous les bras ils ont hissé
un drapeau ukrainien sur l'une des
places centrales de la ville et on dit
attendre l'arrivée des soldats
Ukrainiens ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'il n'aurait pas osé faire
jusqu'à aujourd'hui puisque toute
manifestation d'adhérence à l'Ukraine à
Herson a été très sévèrement puni des
manifest contre l'occupation russe qui
avait eu lieu au mois de mars ont été
réprimés des personnes qui étaient
actifs pour l'Ukraine à Herson ont été
tués ou disparus alors il faut croire
que c'est vraiment un changement qui se
passe en ce moment et que une grande
partie en tout cas des forces russes
sont partis mais les autorités
ukrainiennes ne cessent de mettre en
garde disent aux gens qui sont dans la
ville de Herson de ne pas trop se
déplacer et surtout de ne pas toucher
des objets qui pourraient être suspects
ou des véhicules que les russes auraient
laissé derrière eux parce que ils ont
très peur de mines et de pièges